[Musique]
bonsoir francesco rizutto merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur arte france vous
venez de l'entendre un emmanuel macron
qui appelle à la solidarité européenne
et au final qui chargent les 27
les 27 ans qui charge la commission de
présenter un fonds de relance d'ici le 6
mai uzi croyez ce fonds de relance au
niveau européen pour sauver justement
l'europe de cette terrible crise qui se
profile à corriger sa chance que nous
avons de soyaux les cookies et à la
véritable question suivante est-ce que
cela passera en europe nous allons nous
mettre en place d'autres mécanismes
solution c'est tout ça c'est des mêmes
comment pas de consensus sur des
transferts budgétaires vers certains
pays a dit emmanuel macron être qu'il
faut repenser tout le système
selon vous je sais je suis une réaction
par exemple mon média l'italie je pense
que la situation avance cela ne fait
aucun doute son nom à trouver des
consensus sur les principes d'un fonds
faits de violence il ya également un
sens us sur le passage par la commission
d'ailleurs cela se rajoute avec 540
milliards qui ont déjà été décidées
aujourd'hui il faudrait laisser la place
à davantage d'autonomie d'autonomie pour
les pays davantage de souveraineté vous
pensez que ça serait une meilleure
solution à 100 est à fonctionner déjà
des tendances ans malheureusement l'idée
un virus comme le corps magirus
respecterait les frontières et que nous
pourrions préserver en vue d'ouvrir
leurs frontières
je vais passer fallacieuse je pense que
ce qui va changer suite à sa crise
salutaire c'est que l'on va sûrement
dans le conte au niveau des états
européens
individuellement ou collectivement il
faudra se concentrer bien plus sur les
choses que l'on a laissé à la merci des
marchés ou des pays tiers
il aura donc un attention renforcée sur
ce que mon mac ont appelé la
souveraineté européenne en plus de la
souveraineté nationale
l'europe qui s'est construit en plein
marasme
est-ce que c'est précisément dans ce
genre de crise qu'elle doit selon vous
montrer sa cohésion au contraire il ya
un risque de fracture à l'issue de cette
pandémie qui va être extrêmement
violente on a déjà les premiers chiffres
1 pour l'europe mais pas seulement
washington des véritables problèmes un
rap plus tard parce que porteront les
négociations
les gens vont commencer à repenser à ce
que le rêve à portée les autres pays
je pense que beaucoup de personnes en
europe ceux du sud seront très
mécontentes de la façon dont les pays du
nord de l'europe comme la hollande
notamment les pays bas se sont comportés
le sud
tu me demandez pas au nord de rembourser
toutes ses dettes le sud demandent
quelque chose de complètement différent
je ne suis pas en train de dire que
l'union européenne va se disloquer
mais à moins que les choses avancent
rapidement au cours des mois à venir
alors l'union européenne lui supportera
pas très bien au cours des prochaines
années
aujourd'hui quelle est la situation
parce que même un pays qu'on sait assez
dogmatiques 1 l'allemagne se dit prête à
payer plus même si par exemple sur le
sujet des corps d'un bond et bien ça
reste une ligne rouge pour angela merkel
que faudrait faudrait-il adopté comme
attitude pour ces pays justement je
pense qu il serait mieux de passer par
le budget européen que les biens contre
x plus qu on obtient avec des mèches
transferts c'est par là j'ai surtout sur
les réels efforts seraient obligés va
devoir augmenter de toute façon les
participations avec le brésil et la
perte de la contribution britannique
c'est une sorte une forme de solidarité
qui existe au sein des traités en a donc
besoin d'inventer de nouveaux
instruments de toutes pièces on n'a pas
besoin de se lancer dans des mêmes
politiques au niveau des états pour moi
ce serait la meilleure solution pour
avancer
et bien sûr il faudrait également l'aide
de la bce de la banque d'investissement
et etc
c'est la direction que nous prenons mais
cela ne peut pas durer toujours
aujourd'hui on le voir le commande
chaque jour sur nos antennes chaque pays
a une manière différente de gérer la
crise avec plus ou moins de succès on
citera personne est ce qu'il est normal
qu'à la fin tout le monde contribue de
manière égale selon vous en europe c'est
que je connais toute simple trait
interconnecté donc effectivement nous
allons tous devoir contribuer les
personnes qui ont plus de ressources et
qu'ils ont plus bénéficié du marché
intérieur
devrait à mon sens montrer ce que angela
merkel a qualifié de plus grande
solidarité
un grand succès au cours des deux ou
trois dernières semaines c'est que
l'allemagne même si la rhétorique n'a
pas changé il n'y aura pas de de corona
bond l'allemagne accepte qu'elle devra
endosser plus de responsabilités car
elle a plus de ressources tout
simplement et leur bien-être dépendant
de la prospérité des pays plus plus
faible si cela fait sens merci beaucoup
francesco rizzuto au professeur de droit
européen l'université de hull gilles
merci à vous